thank you
[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
my name is Junaid I'm the chief medical
scientist at Microsoft research and I'm
also the head of global scientific and
Regulatory Affairs within the health
Futures team at Microsoft research
on behalf of Microsoft in our research
Summit I'm really excited to welcome you
to our health Futures Forum discussion
on responsible Equitable and ethical AI
in the context of health and life
sciences
Ai and machine learning Technologies
truly have the potential to transform
the health and Life Sciences research
and indeed go somewhere to augment our
capacity to deliver Precision medicine
and Precision Care
however making sure that AI systems are
developed and deployed responsibly
equitably and ethically especially in
healthcare is one of the toughest
challenges facing AI researchers and
practitioners many questions arise as we
consider the deployment of AI into real
world settings for example what are the
principles that are needed to guide the
deployment of AI monitoring of AI and
machine learning in healthcare how best
can we regulate AI systems and what are
the ways that we can Engage The broader
community of practitioners as our
Technologies are used in real world
settings
in today's session we have a chat
um with three amazing global leaders in
their field who come from a mixture of
regulatory Innovation researcher
backgrounds and clinical backgrounds
themselves I'm delighted to introduce
Dame June rain CEO of the mhra in the UK
trishan punch entrepreneur clinician and
faculty member of the Harvard School of
Public Health and Amy Abernathy
president at alphabets verily and I'll
ask them to do a deeper introduction
into their background shortly
June if I could first come to you
um thank you again for taking the time
to join us here today I'd love for the
audience to to learn a little bit more
about you and your career to date and
perhaps you could share with us a little
bit of who the mha RA are to This Global
audience and let us know a little bit
about what you're doing in the space of
AI
thank you very much indeed Junaid for
this great opportunity to participate in
a panel at this very timely research
Summit
well like my fellow panelists I trained
in medicine and I followed research in
clinical pharmacology after that
specializing in family practice and it
was there I discovered my public health
driver which led to a career focus on
patient safety in relation to medical
devices and medicines my present role as
the CEO of the UK's medicines and
Healthcare products regulatory agency
has been a tremendously exciting
opportunity to strengthen regulation and
and you don't often hear the words
exciting and regulation in the same
sentence
the mhras currently responsible for
ensuring that medicines and medical
devices like software and AI meet
applicable standards of safety of
quality and of Effectiveness promoting
International standardization and
importantly informing the public and
Healthcare professionals about risks and
benefits and contributing to the
development of UK and international
regulatory Frameworks for medical
products so they stay relevant as
technology Medicine Science continue to
advance
so where are we now there's no question
we're in the midst of unprecedented
change in healthcare the regulator has
been Center Stage if you like as we've
introduced new approaches to delivering
safe Innovation for patients and so what
I'd like to say in relation to Ai and
the organizational transformation that
we're putting in place is that we're
building a new concept as an enabler
rather than a watchdog and enabling
regulator that works in partnership not
in isolation while all the time
retaining Independence and a great
example of partnership working one we're
pretty proud of is the collaboration
with the usfda and health Canada which
produced The Guiding principles for good
machine learning practice for medical
device development
these 10 guiding principles quite simply
lay the foundation for developing good
machine learning practice that takes
into account the unique nature of these
products these principle identify areas
where the international medical devices
Regulators forum and the other
International standards organizations
can get together and collaborate
including on Research so the clear
message from our side is that as the AI
and machine learning field evolves so
must best practice and consensus
standards so that brings us bang up to
date I hope
thank you and if I may just quick
follow-up I mean you've spoken a little
bit about
um how you're collaborating with global
Regulators which I think would be
welcome used to to much of the audience
and understanding how we can create both
harmonization and collaboration so that
Innovation can naturally scale what
helped to Regulators need from either
Academia or industry as you start to
think about the regulation of
responsible AI Technologies
well clearly as an exciting new
technology that's going to we hope all
hope to live a massive patient benefit
it also poses novel challenges for
Regulators such as the mhra but here in
the UK we've got an overburdened Health
System we've got lots more demand
increasing costs and limited Supply so
we've got an urgency to develop an
appropriate framework for AI it's part
of the solution it can greatly help with
the issues we're facing and we know what
amazing strides have been made in
imaging radiology histopathology
Etc so we've been involved ourselves in
supporting software and AI products
getting to market the AI reader for the
NHS lateral flow test for example
contact tracing apps across the Nations
to get them into the hands of the public
so what is it that we really need and I
think let's be honest here there are not
yet settled data science and Regulatory
science questions that we don't have a
definitive answer for yet and so we
really want as we talk to Academia and
Industry to get a collaborative approach
so that we can adapt all of us to ensure
this technology gets to the bedside as a
patient safety regulator our primary
concern is safety but it's also access
and I think we're talking about building
it as we fly this plane so we really
need that collaborative approach to put
the science the Bedrock of good
regulation into place
thank you June that that's awesome and
if we now start to think about the
notion of ethical practices within AI
Trisha and I wonder if I could move to
you a little bit and if you could give
us an outline of some of your career to
date
um and indeed maybe a short plug to an
article that you wrote around this
notion of distributed approach to the
regulation of air but before we come to
that maybe we could hear a little bit
about you uh your background your
thoughts in this space
um thanks Jake thanks everyone um yeah I
mean it's a real pleasure to be here and
and thanks very much for the invite I
think you know somewhat appropriate that
um between uh June and Amy who's uh work
and careers are followed obviously for
some time but equally like uh you know
my the first kind of decade I suppose of
my career was spent in the UK
um hence the accent um and I was a
primary care physician as well
risk-based Primary Care in London uh the
second uh decade the second half I
suppose um has been here in the US which
is where I am now in Boston
Massachusetts in the middle was a skin
that Harvard School of Public Health and
in that I we started a digital Health
company back in uh back in 2011 but we
kind of started nurse in 2012 and we
grew up that was World frame we went
through the kind of classic Venture back
route and then we sold that to uh
Blackstone Health Edge back in 2021
um and uh at the end of last year sorry
and since then I've been focusing a lot
on the kind of academic side of what
I've been doing I've been doing that in
the background a little bit there was an
obvious Inception because I think
there's a bunch of really um
conceptually interesting things in
digital Health how you do evaluation
um uh with an alternative to clinical
trials that don't really work very well
for a technology that's been continually
updated
um of course although it's very
necessary to look at the questions that
clinical trials are looking to answer to
exclude known confounders but how do you
exclude unknown confounders how do you
do that in an agile way that works with
software development what are some of
the broader issues in scaling technology
I mean these I think are all I would
argue not just conceptually interesting
but also inherently public health issues
and I'll kind of come on to that in um
uh in a second so so since we since we
saw the Warframe I've been focusing a
little bit more on that side I'm now the
president of the Alumni Association at
hospital public health and uh um I'm in
an instructor there we run a number of
courses one of which
um Junaid you teach hunt we're very
happy to say and Lisa also from
Microsoft as well as a number of other
folks from Google and Amazon and across
industry which is applied AI in
healthcare and I'm generally now looking
a lot at um
these issues of upskilling the clinical
Workforce but also the leadership
Workforce in in terms of digital
literacy and very much looking at
digital transformation of healthcare
organizations very much in the spirit of
what June is saying representing a
National Organization but also smaller
ones individual practices groups of
practices private payers public payers
um there's a real need for the people
running those organizations
um to have a bit more understanding of
this kind of set of methods so they can
work more productively with
organizations such as the one that Amy
represents or the one that I used to in
the past and so we believe that's a
really interesting area
and there's a lot of things that we're
doing in what was previously kind of
called execade we're looking at more of
a lifelong learning model for people
running Healthcare organizations
something I'm working on but equally at
the Masters level as well obviously high
school public health we have a mph and
PhD program so that's kind of what I do
now it's a bit more of a kind of
portfolio portfolio thing
um uh but yeah so so um we just spoke
that specifically so with um some of my
long-term collaborators here at um at
Harvard MIT
um uh uh particularly Leo Chely who was
the founder of the mimic program which
is the largest kind of Open Access
healthcare
um data set
um for machine learning and and Felix
Greaves who has a position at uh the
National Institute of care excellence in
the UK as well as Imperial we looked at
a really kind of practical problem in
that like with the growth of machine
these machine learning Technologies
um uh there's a fundamental volume
problem
um in terms of the regulation of these
Technologies even if you kind of take
aside kind of what could be considered
technical issues but very practical
issues of um you know some of these
things are kind of local by by Design
um if you will and looking at things
that generalize across National
populations may be giving up very useful
local clinical applicability and we
wrote a paper two years ago in Lancer
digital Health
um with some colleagues of ours at
Harvard on the myth of generalizability
um in uh AI medicine
um I believe it is um uh but equally
even if you ignore that and you just
look at things that are calculated
centrally if you look at software as a
medical device or in the FDA I know Amy
and others were very involved in that
pioneering regulation that kind of set
the playing field here in the US and
even if you just look at approvals
things coming out the other side so not
inputs but outputs from that in the
paper we described which is open access
I hope it will be kind of linked um here
it's in plus digital
um uh we found that there was five
approvals in 2015 so obviously kind of
this early in the process in 2020 which
we obviously wrote the paper in 21 that
was the last year we had data there was
95 approvals now from that we're using a
lot of kind of I would argue quite shaky
assumptions we basically I um assume the
kind of linear function of extrapolation
and then felt if if you have that then
there'd be 185 in 2025 and 274 in 2030.
so that's obviously a tripling of the
output of Regulation now I think a
linear function is a massive
underestimate because technology
typically shows an exponential growth
especially when we're at this kind of
point so that's at least the tripling of
the regulate of the resources to
regulate these things centrally that's
assuming that Central regulation is
October which I would argue for things
where you know maybe it's more kind of
smaller units smaller Healthcare units
maybe individual hospitals or individual
clinicians even in a distant future but
some kind of more local collection maybe
in partnership with organizations such
as verily or others who are working with
Healthcare organizations to optimize
pre-trained algorithms on local
populations or retrain them on local
populations to produce locally optimal
results
even if you even if you don't
necessarily buy the local sorry the the
volume problem of doing things centrally
it may not be optimal for things that
should be retrained and reproduced and
reiterated on locally so our paper about
this distributed approach is kind of
discussing a discussing that as a
problem we had folks from the FDA who
had folks from Academia from the UK and
the US
um uh and then proposing this method
which which we could a distributed
method for dealing with it but of course
you know we have to say June is in the
hot seat she has to deliver results Amy
likewise is in an organization where
they have have responsibility both
internally into shareholders we are
merely pontificating it's very easy to
do that um and I appreciate there's lots
of considerations on either side but we
just put it Forward there for debate and
I kind of introduce it here likewise
yeah look forward to the discussion no
thanks so much for having me
thank you and we'll come back to it I
think you raised some interesting points
around both supply and demand mismatch
how do you manage the ever increasing
demand for The Regulators on this at the
same time you also have an exponential
number of drugs coming in for for
licensing approval and June you and I
have spoken in the past in terms of if
you were going to boil down things
around the regulator one does the
product service or innovation do what it
says so does it actually work and two
how do you ensure patient safety not
just for the purposes of approval but
what happens in the in the real world as
well I think that pose is quite an
ethical Challenge and a delivery
challenge within that and and more so if
I think about the ethics of this we also
have to ensure reliability of whatever
these models are that they work and in
healthcare I don't believe you can take
chances and some degree of transparency
upon which what have these models
actually been built on and how do any
regulatory standards groups or people
who take accountability for regulation
have assurance that once deployed they
work like they're they're supposed to in
the real world maybe we can come back to
some of this and the nuances around it
shortly
Amy if I can come come to you now please
if I may and both welcome you and ask
you to perhaps introduce yourself a
little bit about your eclectic
background you seem to have had multiple
careers in a single lifetime
um and I'm sure the audience would love
to learn more
you and it's a delight and honor to be
the rest of the panel I'm a physician by
background as well I'm an oncologist and
when I was taking care of patients in
the clinic I'm a melanoma doctor I was
really
um motivated some sometimes horrified by
really this issue that we were
developing
potentially life-saving medical products
in our Laboratories actually on both
sides of my clinic and the length of
time it would take from me for
Meaningful safe and effective products
to get to the people who would need them
and that was really the motivating
factor for pretty much everything across
my career so when I was at Duke
University as a professor of medicine I
was also running something called the
Center for Learning Healthcare where we
were trying to understand how do you
line up evidence development and
understanding how new treatments perform
and the delivery of those treatments so
that that was much more facile and
connected and continuously learning
uh as I was doing my work at Duke what I
realized was we hit a ceiling especially
as it related to the ability to scale
um and the ability to build the kinds of
software and data capabilities that were
needed to pull that off
I then went to a company called Flatiron
Health in New York City or where I was
the chief medical officer and chief
scientific officer and what we were
doing was developing solutions to curate
to clean up electronic health record
data in the cancer space to be able to
create data sets that reflected care
delivery so real world data sets that
then could be used for a variety of
research tasks including regulatory
grade decisions and that work then led
to a lot of activity in the real world
data and real world evidence side I
worked on 21st century cures in the
United States and ultimately flat iron
Health was bought by Roche in 2018 and
as I was scratching my head trying to
decide what was the next thing to do I
realized that really the the regulatory
function regulation and an agency like
the Food and Drug Administration as a
science-based public health agency is an
incredible public Health mechanism to
drive forward the development of safe
and effective treatments and so I went
to FDA in February 2019 as principal
Deputy Commissioner and was there I also
became the Chief Information officer and
I'll come back to the reason why in just
a second and was that FDA until
April of last year I joined verily as
president of clinical research platforms
about 15 months ago and the reason why I
did this is because I could see in the
middle of the pandemic that our ability
to develop new Solutions is really
unbelievable but our clinical trials
capabilities are Circa 1995. how we
think about evaluating Medical Products
is still not based on the best of what's
possible with respect to data and
technology and that's what we're really
focused on at barely
verily itself is one of the alphabet
companies as you mentioned and um we are
a company focused on unlock blocking the
promise of Precision Health for everyone
every day if that's going to be true
we're going to need to leverage ai-based
Solutions we're going to need to build
those Solutions we need to leverage
solutions to do tasks like building
better evidence generation capabilities
and we also need to make sure that the
work we're doing is fair and Equitable
and represents all people and we'll come
back to that the last thing I thought
I'd say
um in in reference is
the the thing that I saw at FDA and goes
along with what we've just been talking
about with um June and Sean kind of hit
on this was that if we have an
increasing number of Sam D products we
have more and more selling Gene
therapies and every other treatments the
regulatory tasks are scaling quickly and
we need to build the regulatory
functions to go along with those scaling
tasks and so when I was FDA we put
forward the data and Tech modernization
action plans to build the agency in my
in modern ways to be able to keep pace
and then as I've come to verily I've
really focused on how do we build new
evidence generation capabilities that
can also evaluate these products and
also evaluate them longitudinally across
their life life cycle much of which
require sophisticated computation and AI
thank you I mean there's so much there
and if I could pick up on one of the
things you mentioned was this notion of
equity which I think is has become even
more apparent through the pandemic and
it's clearly been of interest for people
with a public health background
um or indeed people looking at
population Health more broadly I often
hear about responsible AI as a generic
term but I think within Healthcare we
must extend that to truly think about
um the equity of healthcare the ethics
of healthcare and this notion of
responsibility alongside how do you
think about Equity broadly and how do
you think about it in the context of the
development of AI tools
so as I think about this concept of
equity broadly it means that our health
care Delivery Systems and the treatments
and interventions that are being
developed need to be able to work for
all people and as we have systems that
bias or leave people out we are both not
Equitable and also not fair and so as we
think about what we need to do we need
to actually look towards how do we solve
the gaps and that means first we have to
recognize that gaps exist gaps exist in
data gaps exist in process gaps exist in
healthcare delivery and learn how to
bridge those gaps and do so in ways that
don't call into question whether or not
we should be doing it but make sure that
it is true that we are just doing it
because that's the right way to deliver
Health Care
practically speaking it means we need to
solve for data gaps and be able to
develop more appropriate and
representative data sets and I'll also
be able to measure and solve for bias it
means we need to develop solutions for
process gaps so how do we make sure that
our Solutions represent all people but
also reach all people and then we also
need to develop better Solutions towards
transparency so we are able to
understand what people need but also
talk in a way and communicate in a way
and Reach people in a way that in the
line so that they can actually each
person say this is what I need what I
want for my personal health care in a
way that represents my personal values
brilliant and I think as I think about
what you all have said it's not just
doing the right thing which could be the
Innovation The Invention but it's how we
do it so doing it in the right way is
going to be critically important and
then in addition to that thinking about
the evidence that we we Supply around it
bringing you together now as a real
panel I suppose
um I there's I saw trishan writing uh
furiously a few things and I'll probably
bring him in for for some commentary
shortly but there's clearly a supply and
demand challenge so we know there's a
tsunami of innovation coming our way
from Academia from industry uh from
homegrown opportunities within the
provider landscape as well yet we're not
we don't I don't understand Regulators
are necessarily funded to deliver
against all of this massive ambition in
that ecosystem so you could argue this
notion of distributive regulatory
systems may be something for us to think
about if we take that as an initial
topic Juno maybe if I could come to you
any any initial views or thoughts on
that and maybe taking in some of the
learning from the pandemic where the UK
uh correct me if I'm wrong was amongst
the first in the world to really deeply
look at the MRNA vaccine vaccines that
have never been produced in this way
before and think about how do you
um safely regulate them and I know you
United this before but I often wonder
whether we're in a large real world
evidence study to even today with mRNA
vaccines and we're continually reviewing
the safety profile of them if that is
true then actually the central regulator
truly has a role around Innovation but
maybe I could come to you with your
thoughts on that
absolutely
concept of getting Invasion say
time was
in Spotlight as in the pandemic and it
meant I think the old saying is that the
people who do best in the face of a
challenge aren't the strongest
toughest
smartest they're the most flexible and
therefore every flexibility was brought
to bear within the laws that we we have
the question I think that we're now
talking about with
um software as a medical device AI is
how we adapt even further and we often
talk about risk proportionality not one
size fits all so we've got to drive that
to its fullest potential there are many
this dare I say it products coming
through that aren't that high risk and
therefore in terms of trishan's thoughts
about a distributed model we already
have the ability to bring on board
approved bodies formally called notified
bodies that would take away more simple
and straightforward and we've been here
before type work
not to dismiss it at all it's really
important but then the regulator is
focusing on the high risk you know where
we want to get stuff through to the
patient to the bedside quickly and the
uncertainties are greater and in that
scenario we're bringing on board as
Amy's saying some really great data
generation tools the one doesn't go
without the other the way we were able
to introduce mRNA vaccines quickly in
the shortest time we we needed was
because we had those data generation
tools we had them in place six months
before we approved and that was the
priority at greater uncertainty a real
drive to generate data and I think with
some of those principles we can employ
them for the amazing opportunities we
have now is not to dismiss what trishon
is saying at all it is a sumat tsunami
but we should embrace it and run to it
amazing and Trisha before I come to you
I'm going to come to Amy just both with
her previous and her current hat maybe
thinking through what are your thoughts
or Reflections Amy just on
um the provocation I suppose that
churchan poses uh you know so first of
all the provocation is in response
partly to as you pointed out to Sean and
the the scaling number of cmd's
solutions but journals have pointed out
another point of scale um that's in
front of us uh that makes this even more
complex which is the evaluation of
medical products multiply across their
life cycle so as you pointed out with uh
the coveted vaccines we're now
continuously evaluating them including
asking questions of duration of
Effectiveness and safety and do you need
a booster and can you mix and match a
myocarditis all of these questions and
so the the multiplicity is the scaling
number of products and the scaling
number of evaluation time points for any
um given product and so you know
practically speaking we're going to need
Solutions whether that's distributed
evaluation and regulation or new ways of
evaluating the solutions that put that
to test a couple of observations the
first is the pandemic did teach us that
we can regulate in new ways and as June
said you know within the confines of the
law and it's very important that we that
we keep that in mind but as we develop
flexible and new ways of regulating one
of the things I saw at FDA was the
importance of not only regulatory
flexibility but what I call building
regulatory muscle so as we start to
think about more flexible ways of
regulating allowing multiple groups
public-private Partnerships with
Regulators at the table to say here's
what I trust here's what I don't trust
here's what I need to see in order to
have confidence and do this differently
and that's a very important aspect as we
develop new regulatory approaches and
some of that for example was tested out
in the some of the pilots that the
center responsible for regulating CMD
products at FDA cdrh really was pushing
forward in the pre-certification pilot
really just asking the question how do
we pressure test regulating in new ways
and what does that teach us another
thing that you know I've seen and I I
think a lot about is are products like
our samd products often are based on
data and get a give off data so if we're
thoughtful about these products we can
also be thoughtful about their
continuous evaluation through the data
that is generated and so developing
solutions for continuous evaluation of
performance is pretty critical and I
think that product developers can
incorporate that in what they're doing
and so I encourage us to both have
regulatory creativity but also for
manufacturers to have creativity as well
trishan if I can come see you yeah it's
interesting I mean I I don't disagree
with that actually I mean so so and and
yeah I mean of course you know we're
kind of like splitting for kind of
effects I suppose I mean I think there's
there's a lot that we're growing here
it's um okay so I think I mean I I mean
I mean those two points like each one in
turn that's made so one of course yes
like uh proportionality so you know
based on risk so things that are likely
to be delivered in an entirely
autonomous fashion or a designed to be
living in an autonomous fashion or
things that are National by design for
uh automation of national screening
programs for example like those things
should clearly look they look more like
a drug or a medical device and they
should go through that process and
typically organizations that are doing
that have the industrial scale to do it
and I don't think there's there's
certainly no debate for me or my other
kind of academic colleagues in um in
that area I think Amy uh raises a very
important point which I I think is is a
real challenge for regulation and it was
brought up with software you know prior
to any use of machine learning just
purely kind of deterministic
pre-programmed software is the the kind
of Agile development methodology that's
kind of core to all software generation
these days
um uh necessarily involves regular
reiteration so once something is
evaluated or approved and if it's
applied on one population then it's the
job of the organizations that we all
work for actually you know the
organization that's convening this
um this panel to try and continuously
improve that software and in hiring
people who are very good at that but
then that's a very interesting
regulatory question so that software
after five iterations is it the same as
that thing that was regulated in the
first place or does it need to be redone
if so how often and what level of data
is applicable for that now if you're
going to go purely kind of um
canonically I suppose by the textbook in
your game for like randomized control
trials or even aggregations of
randomized control trials or even higher
standard that's kind of just there
aren't the resources for that
um uh certainly either kind of any real
examples where anyone's done multiple
randomized controlled trials over time
to evaluate software as it's being
reiterated and rather than that what you
have is individual organizations and
vendors coming to an agreement that well
yeah it's kind of roughly the same and
we trust you and we'll work with you and
that element of trust and partnership
working that I know is called to
Microsoft and yeah it's a quarter very
least quarter to all organizations that
have been able to do this at scale it's
what we did
um at Warframe I think is absolutely key
here it's like partnership for digital
transformation and that involves
um kind of navigating these gray areas
or these areas where regulation can't
really give you guidance and even if
these things are nationally regulated as
they continually evolve there's some
amount of uncertainty there and I would
use kind of what's necessarily always
going to be that way just because of its
volume problem and then I think the
other issue that we haven't discussed
those yet but it's very real is like
what about kind of a you know more
distant future where you have and I
think it's a future that many people
certainly um
uh the um a laboratory computational
physiology that that I joined at mites
it was back in 2011 they had this Vision
that you could have ICU data sets
locally that were aggregated and you
could have local coalitions of data
scientists and clinicians working
together to develop uh prognostication
models prediction models or
classification diagnostic models for
local populations and they would be they
wouldn't necessarily be generalizable
but they would be optimized for that
local population and they could be
implemented in a that's a really cool
vision and I remember back as a student
when I first heard about that I'm like
this is the future of medicine it's like
clearly what should happen but in that
kind of world
that's very difficult to look at even
you know any of the approaches to
regulation that we've discussed it's
very very tricky to to incorporate those
cases especially at scale
um so I think you know that was kind of
one of the and you know I would argue
that ICU is probably ahead of other
fields in terms of because it's
obviously just by Design very data rich
and the work of uh mimic and uh and the
lab for well over a decade now
um uh has capitalized that I'm sure a
lot of people watching this would have
used mimic um I believe there's still
like three papers published every single
week on the on the mimic data set and
that's been the way for the last decade
so so
um uh but imagine that rather than
people doing it as their phds or their
research work postdocs working in
industry it's actually individual
Healthcare organizations developing that
themselves now that is a real I mean
it's really cool for a mid clinical
point of view I think for patients it's
really cool it's like a really great
vision of like data informed medicine
that I think is very much in keeping
with like some of the personalized
medicine uh and even like learning
system
um visions of The Institute of medicine
Etc and some of the bodies locally but
it so really complicated regulatory
issues that and I think that's the you
know that's the kind of spirit of um how
we're thinking about this kind of very
much in the long range I mean I think in
the short term the medium term I agree
with everything that's been said and I
guess in the long term we'll all figure
it out but I'm we're just kind of posing
those questions
there's so much in this discussion and
I'm sure we could write multiple papers
on it and have longer discussions I know
and I've had the privilege of having
one-to-ones with you 45 minutes doesn't
seem long enough before we kind of get
into the nitty-gritty of some of these
things and I know it's probably worth us
just pausing just before we we
collectively close to say the regulatory
aspect is only one part of the wider
Health Innovation ecosystem you need
providers to be set up for whatever the
Innovation that's been regulated to do
their best work we need to really engage
public patients and Society so that they
understand how some of these Innovations
are being deployed and the impact that
they're having with them and so I think
that there's that wider Healthcare
System debate that we perhaps need to
have on a on a separate occasion around
what needs to change across not just
regulation but the Innovation provider
environment and indeed the the patient
public trust aspect of things in order
for some of these Innovations to truly
see the light of day
and as as we close perhaps I could try
to bring us back around this notion of
responsible Equitable ethical Ai and if
we could futurecast for a moment what
would be any key asks or recommendations
that you would have for this research
big Tech Community
um that if you had one ask one call to
action if you will what would that be
perhaps trishana could come to you first
well okay so I really strongly believe
in two things uh uh well I mean I
believe a number of things but the two
things that are relevant here it's um uh
so the first is that the best ideas come
from the margins um you know obviously
I'm kind of an entrepreneur at heart
here I'm also an immigrant so I have
some kind of bias there but like you
know I I believe that's fundamentally
true and it's the uh job of big Tech as
the individual Regulators to try and
make sure there's exactly as June said
that there's a path for those things to
reach scale there's a path for those
ideas to be supported I also really
believe that like the um digital
transformation particularly kind of
cloud transformation is a really I I
would say it's you know it's gonna in
future looking back it's going to be
considered similar to kind of Sanitation
infrastructure data infrastructure is
just going to be essential Healthcare
infrastructure and it would seem uh
eccentric for the for our future selves
looking backwards that that wasn't
thought of in kind of uh centralized
manner um or or it wasn't a kind of
coherence
so I think those two things and that's
like you know if you look at Cloud
obviously
um Microsoft Google Amazon are the big
three in terms of cloud providers they
are now and will continue to be
providing essential kind of Health
infrastructure in much the way that like
sanitation infrastructure was core
infrastructure or public health system
in the past so that so that brings
aligns the in the long-term interests I
think naturally
um at a very fundamental level of large
technology organizations much Healthcare
organizations and then I think at more
at the applied level like I think on top
of that it's you know and I have some
bias here because I'm more on the kind
of Entrepreneurship side myself it's a
question of how does big Tech and
government work to try and create the
conditions much as Amy and June have
have identified and continued commitment
to doing that to make sure the best
ideas that may be coming from Individual
clinicians individual health care
organizations startups can get to scale
which is obviously there's there's a
bunch of challenges in doing that and
helping it takes a long time
thank you Amy your thoughts any key
requests recommendations for this
community before us today
first piece is on on the Equitable
Equitable AI um the reminder that not
only do we need the data sets to build
algorithms for those data sets need to
be representative and not biased and we
need to measure that bias but then we
need to also constantly evaluate the
performance of the algorithms that we're
building to ensure that the algorithms
perform as expected and themselves do
not lead to more bias in health care so
that that part I think we need to see is
foundational my my ask and my
encouragement to This research Community
is to think about how we can leverage AI
not just to build samd products but AI
to actually help to solve a lot of the
problems and challenges across
especially the evidence generation space
that includes AI to help us curate data
sets AI to help us run better clinical
trials whether that's operational
efficiency or AI based informed clinical
trials um and Bayesian trials for
example we also should be thinking about
AI AI to help us build for example novel
endpoints like digital endpoints all of
these need to be tested we need to make
sure that these ai-based Solutions again
lead to better evidence generation
faster smarter and not biased but I
submit that one of the ways to get to
more Equitable Health Care is to make
sure that we develop more products that
actually work for everyone and AI can be
a part of the solution set for building
those products
thank you and last but not least June
your thoughts well the principle we
Embrace every day in regulation is
regulation follows science and as we
Face these immense opportunities and
this panel debate has really flagged
some of the the tough questions but huge
opportunities I think the big ask is
Let's Travel together it is going to be
quite a journey and we're excited now
we'll probably reach a stage of thinking
some of this is impossible but I think
if we travel it together we will
actually inter with our
interdependencies we will achieve great
things at the mhra we realize the
enormity of of what we're looking at and
so we're publishing a roadmap as you do
as a regulator with broken down work
packages that together we can start to
tussle with the questions we've heard a
whole range of a panoply of things that
we all say yes we must do this we need
the clear data sets in the UK we've got
the benefit of the National Health
Service and the data it holds as a test
bed like the recovery trial and we can
make synthetic data sets from data that
we hold we can use AI ourselves there's
nothing like using tools yourself as we
did in the pandemic that demonstrates
we're bought in we want to be part of
this amazing world and so single message
let's travel together
thank you and my sincere thanks to all
of you for this immensely Rich
discussion and for being part of our
extended Healthcare Futures community
and family it's been a real pleasure to
speak with all of you today and my
thanks to you and for the audience for
their engagement in our session thank
you thanks everyone thank you everyone
foreign
[Music]